close time the idea here is you can
travel back in time but you can't
actually change history so if you go
back and try and prevent the
assassination of President McKinley it
turns out that you kill him yourself or
if you go back and try and prevent the
Black Plague it turns out that you are a
flea-ridden disease drat this creates
weird effects for instance if you find
an ancient solid gold potato ricer in
your backyard you can go back in time
and place it there yourself which raises
the question what created the solid gold
potato ricer in the first place you'd
think that nothing could exist in a
monotonous pointless loop of untimed
with no beginning or end but in my
experience that describes most
laundromats a minus branching timelines
this model holds that you can't actually
change a given time line rather when you
go back in time time itself splits like
dry flyaway hair into alternate
universes enough time travel and you end
up with universes where apes evolved
from laurel trees or there was once an
intelligent conversation on dick I think
that in situations like this people
would start to immigrate from the crappy
timelines to the nice ones possibly
forming gated communities with alternate
universe versions of themselves and
having potluck swear everyone ends up
bringing the potato salad be linear time
you go back in time you change time you
return to a very different now but what
if you go back in time and kill your own
grandfather before you were born it's
pretty much inevitable I mean going back
in time without killing your own
grandfather that's like going to
Philadelphia not having a cheesesteak
but once you kill your grandfather then
of course you'll never be born which
means you can't go back in time to kill
your grandfather etc etc etc to prevent
this a lot of movies like to throw in
arbitrary loopholes like you have 24
hours whatever 24 hours means when your
time traveling to go back and set things
right it turns out that explicit
causality is very important for box
office revenues B+ self-repairing time
in this model time is like a drug addict
that really wants to change but keeps
backsliding so if you go back in time to
1974 and throw Bill Gates off a cliff
suddenly some guy named Gil dates will
put on glasses get a bad haircut and
start a software company this is a
popular bottle of time for authors who
don't like thinking too much it's
because you can write a story where
South America was eaten by a giant space
capybara in the 80s but you can still
get a cinnamon dulce latte at Starbucks
d bad time according to this there's a
single correct timeline one that needs
to be enforced by some sort of temporal
police how can you tell which is the
correct time well of course it's the one
where someone formed a temporal police
force in fact I suspect that the time
cops main job is to prevent the forming
of a timeline where people are free and
happy without any interference from a
temporal police force this is also known
as hippie time continued existence is
the ultimate job security d-plus